[Musique]
m
depuis l'âge de 8 ans stéphane vinet ne
quitte plus son piano se vit si noah qui
enseigne la musique deux fois par
semaine à la batterie de guyancourt a
découvert le jazz grâce à un ami de ses
parents
et quand même et quand même jouer ça je
me demandais vraiment ce que c'était
quoi cette musique
ce blu ce que je découvrirai mais
vraiment bien plus tard parce que mes
parents écoutaient absolument pas cette
musique et donc j'ai été fascinée jeu
voilà pourquoi je me suis je me suis
tourné vers cette musique vers 20 ans il
intègre une école de jazz à cachan puis
par une formation diplômante pour
enseigner mais 7 février prochain les
sons jazzy de son dernier album
résonneront dans l'auditorium de l'école
de musique de guyancourt stéphane vinet
sera accompagné de son kart est
interprétera des morceaux de la f110
sortie en 2013
particularité chacune des compositions
sera accompagné d'une oeuvre picturale
on va essayer de
d'adapter en fait les
les morceaux en fonction des toiles qui
seront projetés puisque ma mère a peint
ses toiles en écoutant la musique
voilà donc les photos ont été prises
après et puis on a fait la pochette du
disque
voilà donc ce sera le concert sera
habillé de cette manière là en parallèle
de ce concert stéphane vinet entrera en
studio pour enregistrer un troisième
album
la date de sortie est prévue en juin
prochain
[Musique]
à